und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und eine Gellinek
guten Abend die Reise der EU-Spitzen
nach Kiew ist gefährlich einerseits des
Krieges wegen am Morgen wurde in der
gesamten Ukraine Luftalarm ausgelöst
gefährlich aber auch wegen der in die
Höhe getriebenen ukrainischen
Erwartungen die am Ende eigentlich nur
enttäuscht werden können der
EU-Beitrittsprozess ist eine ermüdende
langwierige Prozedur ein Dschungel von
Regeln und Gesetzen muss übernommen
Kriterien erfüllt werden von all dem
Sprachen die EU-Spitzen heute in Kiew
wenig Sie überboten sich lieber in
Sympathie Bekundungen Bekundungen für
einen von Russland überfallenes Land und
heizten damit die Erwartungen weiter an
Florian Neuhann berichtet
der Himmel ist grau an diesem Tag in
Kiew
und das Geräusch das des Kriegs
Luftalarm am Tag an dem Europas Spitzen
ebenso in Kiew die Zukunft des Landes
rosarot malen so rosarot wie nur möglich
die Ukraine und die EU wir sind Familie
die Ukraine ist eine wahre Inspiration
Ukraine ist die EU die EU ist die
Ukraine
seit Monaten liefern sich
EU-Ratspräsident Charlie Michelle und
kommissionspräsidentin Ursula von der
Leyen einen inoffiziellen Wettbewerb wer
reist häufiger in die Ukraine und wer
verspricht dort am meisten es geht um
Geld Sanktionen Waffen und über allem
auch heute um einen möglichen Beitritt
in die EU wo die Ukraine drängt
unser Ziel ist es die
Beitrittsverhandlungen in diesem Jahr zu
starten
das ist ehrgeizig erst seit Juni ist die
Ukraine offiziell EU-Beitrittskandidat
so wie sieben andere Staaten im Herbst
soll die EU-Kommission formal die
Fortschritte bewerten dann entscheiden
die Mitgliedstaaten einstimmig über die
Aufnahme von Verhandlungen verhandelt
wird meist über Jahre am Ende müssen
wieder alle 27 Staaten einer Aufnahme
zustimmen
und da sind längst nicht alle so
euphorisch wie die EU-Spitzen in Kiew
schon im vergangenen Mai mahnt
Frankreichs Präsident macron bist du
einem Beitritt könnten Jahrzehnte
vergehen und im Herbst gibt sich
Bundeskanzler Scholz rhetorisch offen
verlangt aber vor einer Erweiterung erst
eine EU-Reform nur das von einer solchen
Reform derzeit kaum jemand etwas wissen
will und den Kiew währenddessen niemand
etwas von den Hindernissen was ihr Land
denn erwarten könne fragt eine
ukrainische Journalistin den
EU-Ratspräsidenten
natürlich das ist ein Verfahren bei dem
sie eine einstimmige Entscheidung der
Mitgliedstaaten brauchen aber ich bin
zuversichtlich bis Ende dieses Jahres
wird ein EU-Gipfel die nächsten Schritte
dieses Beitrittsprozesses entschieden
haben
es ist die Formulierung die einem
Versprechen noch am nächsten kommt
während der ukrainische Präsident auf
eine andere Anfrage der nach
Langstreckenwaffen heute keine Antwort
erhält stattdessen preist Ursula von der
Leyen was die EU der Ukraine nun spendet
Energiesparbirnen zusammen bringen wir
das Licht heißt es dort weniger Pathos
war heute offenbar nicht drin
und zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt unser
brüsselkorrespondent Ulf Höller guten
Abend Ulf das war ja eine ziemliche
harmonieshow heute in Kiew wenn wir die
Sympathie Girlanden mal weglassen welche
realen Hindernisse liegen noch auf dem
Weg zum EU-Beitritt der Ukraine
als wenn man sich mal dieses visuelle
Feuerwerk wegdenkt und sich davon nicht
blenden lässt dann sieht man eben dass
diese Vorstellung der Ukraine in zwei
Jahren vielleicht sogar EU-Mitglied zu
sein eine völlige Illusion ist und trotz
hat viele Küsschen gegeben und viel
Handshake aber es hat nichts Konkretes
eben von der Kommission gegeben sondern
die klare Ansage es gibt kein Zeitplan
sondern die Ukraine muss ganz normal
wieder alle anderen auch durch diesen
bald spitzprozess und da ist das große
große Hindernis für die Ukraine eben die
Korruption ohne die Mangel der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit die Kommission sagt
zwar dass die Ukraine sogar im Krieg
Fortschritt bei der
Korruptionsbekämpfung macht aber das
würde bei weitem noch nicht ausreichen
und dann gibt es noch eine argumentieren
Brüssel das nicht so laut gesagt wird
weil die Ukraine im Krieg ist und man
keine Gefühle verletzen will aber im
Grunde genommen ist es ein sehr sehr
armes sehr sehr großes Land mit einer
riesen Agrarindustrie und wenn die
Ukraine dann mal EU Mitglied ist würden
dort Milliarden von Subventionen fließen
die Mitgliedern fehlen und das führt
auch dazu dass nicht alle begeistert
sind wenn die Ukraine kommt es gibt noch
einen Punkt bei dem der Präsident
selensky und die EU unterschiedliche
Sprachen sprechen und das ist das Thema
Waffenlieferung welche Missverständnisse
gibt es hier
also ich glaube dieses Missverständnis
kann sich wirklich zu einem doch tief
greifender und Konflikt auswachsen auf
der einen Seite ist der lensky und die
Osteuropäer und die baltischen Staaten
die in der EU sind und die wollen halt
immer mehr Waffen nach der
panzergeschichte jetzt kommt die
Forderung nach Langstreckenwaffen und
nach Kampfjets man hat hier halt in
dieser Region unglaublich Angst von den
Russen überrannt zu werden und auf der
anderen Seite sind vor allem die
deutschen die von diesen permanenten
neuen Waffen Forderungen genervt sind
weil der Bundeskanzler doch sehr
deutlich gemacht hat dass man eben nicht
in eine Eskalation mit diesen
Waffensystem reinkommen will mit Moskau
und diese zwei Positionen sind
eigentlich nicht miteinander zu
verbinden und so um so umso länger der
Kriege geht glaube ich dass dieser
Konflikt auch immer deutlicher wird
aus Brüssel mit ein bisschen Realpolitik
neben der beitrittslyrik danke dahin
der Ballon ist so groß wie drei
Autobusse und er fliegt seit einigen
Tagen in großer Höhe über Kanada und dem
US-Bundesstaat Montana sein Auftraggeber
China sein Ziel mutmaßlich Spionage
China dagegen spricht von einem
Flugobjekt zur Wetterbeobachtung das
versehentlich abgedriftet sei dieser
Balance jedenfalls ließ heute die erste
China-Reise eines amerikanischen
Außenministers seit 2018 platzen und er
zeigt wie instabil und angespannt die
amerikanisch chinesischen Beziehungen
sind MRT Wissen berichtet aus Washington
auf den ersten Blick macht das überhaupt
keinen Sinn ein riesiger spionageballon
über Montana unübersehbar ausgerechnet
vor dem geplanten Besuch des
us-außenministers in Peking dreist so
ein eifern sich Politiker bei der
Parteien hier im Fernsehen und rätseln
über das Warum wieso macht China dass
die USA doch rund um die Uhr mit seinen
Satelliten aus spät so etwas
sie suchen offenbar nach Informationen
die sie nicht per Satellit gewinnen
können das ist ein schamloser Akt wir
müssen politisch gegenhalten Amerikas
Souveränität verteidigen und den
Chinesen klarmachen dass wir das nicht
tolerieren
immerhin schwebte der Balance from Basis
in Montana wo Atomraketen stationiert
sind
US-Kampfjets waren kurz davor den
Eindringling aus China abzuschießen aber
das Pentagon wollte nicht dass
Zivilisten zu Schaden kommen
Chinas Behauptung ein Wetterballon sei
versehentlich sehr weit abgedriftet
glaubt hier keiner
die Präsenz dieses überwachungsbalance
im US-Luftraum ist eine klare Verletzung
der amerikanischen Souveränität und
internationalen Rechts ein
unverantwortlicher Akt und die
Entscheidung China so etwas am Vorabend
meines Besuches zu tun ist schädlich für
die Substanz unserer Gespräche
also sagte blinken den Besuch in Peking
ab dabei weiß er genau das auch die USA
China ständig ausspionieren so
entdeckten sie neue Silos für
chinesische Atomraketen in der Wüste
Gobi und fanden heraus dass in dieser
Test Einrichtung für Chinas neue
Überschall Raketen Mikrochips mit
amerikanischem Know-how verwendet wurden
von der Firma Cadence in Kalifornien der
Ballon ist wohl auch Teil des
Vorgeplänkels für den Konflikt zwischen
Amerika und China sie wollen bis 2049
den Indopazifik dominieren und die
Weltordnung mit neuen Regeln das ist
ihre große Strategie
energy deshalb schickt China immer
wieder Kampfjets in die neutrale Zone um
Taiwan und deshalb verwandelt es
idyllische Atolle im Südpazifik in
Flugzeug und Raketenbasen dagegen
schmiedet Joe Biden Bündnisse will jede
Weitergabe von Hochtechnologie an China
verhindern mit Japans premier kishida
vereinbarte er gerade die Stationierung
von Raketen auf Okinawa
Verteidigungsminister Austin holte sich
diese Woche beim philippinischen
Präsidenten Markos die Zusage das
us-truppenbasen im Norden des Landes
nutzen dürfen für China eine Provokation
für die USA eine klare Linie um Taiwan
im Konfliktfall beizustehen
das ist ein sehr wichtiger Schritt für
die Vereinigten Staaten das gibt uns
zusätzliche Fähigkeiten wenn wir Taiwan
verteidigen müssen
dass ich beide Seiten ausspionieren
wissen Sie ganz genau im November
wollten sie auch deshalb weiter im
Gespräch bleiben entschied das nicht
mehr will bekommt das hier einen Sinn
als unübersehbares Signal das China den
Konflikt verschärft
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und die beginnen mit dem
Dauerbrenner panzerlieferung Gundula die
Bundesregierung hat der Ukraine die
Lieferung weiterer Kampfpanzer zugesagt
zusätzlich zu den bereits angekündigten
14 Leopard 2 gibt es jetzt grünes Licht
für Lieferungen des ausgemusterten
Vorgängermodells Leopard 1 rund 100
davon stehen bei einer Rüstungsfirma in
Flensburg der rhein-metall-konzern soll
bereits im April erklärt haben er könne
88 Panzer modernisieren und
bereitstellen unklar ist allerdings wie
viele dann tatsächlich saniert und
ausgeführt werden Munition für den
Leopard 1 soll im Ausland gekauft werden
auch die USA weiten ihre Militärhilfen
für die Ukraine aus für noch einmal fast
2,2 Milliarden Dollar sollen jetzt nach
Monaten des Zögerns auch Raketen mit
einer Reichweite von bis zu 150 km
geliefert werden die USA hatten Sorge
damit tiefer in den Konflikt
hineingezogen zu werden die ukrainische
Armee rechnet in den nächsten Wochen mit
einer neuen russischen Offensive in den
letzten 24 Stunden wurden nach
ukrainischen Angaben bei Angriffen der
Russen sechs Zivilisten getötet und
weitere 20 verletzt
bayerischen Ermittlern ist ein Schlag
gegenbetreiber von Plattformen gelungen
die im Darknet sexualisierte Gewalt
gegen Kinder zeigten drei Webseiten
wurden stillgelegt mehrere Verdächtige
in Großbritannien und den USA
festgenommen ein 22-Jähriger deutscher
der Fotos und Videos zugänglich gemacht
haben soll sitzt in Untersuchungshaft
die Ermittler gehen von tausenden
Nutzern aus zahlreiche sein
identifiziert worden
nach der Bestätigung ihrer
Spitzenkandidatur bei der Landtagswahl
in Hessen wird die Kritik an
bundesinnenministerin Faser lauter vor
allem aus der Opposition aus der Union
heißt es das werde nicht funktionieren
das Land vertrage keine
teilzeitministerin die Partei Gremien
der hessischen SPD haben die
Bundesministerin heute einstimmig zur
Spitzenkandidatin für die Landtagswahl
am 8 Oktober nominiert Faser hatte
angekündigt im Falle einer Wahl
Niederlage Innenministerin bleiben zu
wollen
es hat schon gedauert bis die neue
italienische Regierungschefin zum
Antrittsbesuch nach Berlin gekommen ist
offiziell wegen Terminschwierigkeiten
Georgia melloni regiert Italien seit
etwas über 100 Tagen mit einer stramm
rechten Koalition angeführt von der
eigenen Partei den postfaschistischen
Brüdern Italiens Meloni selbst hatte im
Wahlkampf gedroht wenn sie ins Amt käme
sei der Spaß für Europa vorbei und das
deutsche Diktat in der EU zu Ende
bislang aber gibt sich die italienische
Regierungschefin in der Außenpolitik
eher handzahm und nicht nur im
Kanzleramt fragt man sich ob man ob
Melone sich nur verstellt oder ob sie es
ernst meint Andreas Kühnast und Annette
hilsenbeck berichten
da steht Georgia Meloni deren Partei vor
Deutschland gewarnt hat und will nicht
wiederholen dass sie allergisch ist
gegen Deutsch und eine Abneigung hat
gegen das Land und da steht Olaf Scholz
dessen Partei vor der wahlmelonis
gewarnt hat und will nicht wiederholen
dass ein Gast Italien in die falsche
Richtung lenkt signora Meloni und Herr
Scholz versuchen von vorn anzufangen sie
müssen unsere Regierung haben sich immer
eng miteinander abgestimmt und wir beide
sind fest entschlossen die enge
Zusammenarbeit vorzusetzen die Frau die
Europa die Deutschland den Kampf
angesagt hatte ist seit 100 und vier
Tagen im Amt und kämpft nicht gegen
sondern mit Europa Meloni steht
felsenfest an der Seite der Ukraine
lässt Hilfsgüter und Waffen liefern
obwohl ihre Koalitionspartner als sehr
russlandfreundlich gelten keine
Regierung Italiens seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg stand so weit rechts wie
melonis 29-köpfige Ministerriege sie ist
postfaschistin ihre Partei hat sich
nicht historisch von Mussolini
abgenabelt und wir werden jetzt ganz
genau gucken ob sie sich an die
demokratischen Spielregel hält so ganz
genau man auch guckt bisher hält sich
Meloni an die meisten Spielregeln der EU
vor ihrer Wahl hatte sie Brüssel Schluss
mit lustig zu gerufen aber dann begann
sie messbar ernst ihr erster Haushalt
hält alle finanzregeln ein Reformen
werden fortgesetzt teure Wahlversprechen
kassiert aufeinander prallen die Welten
beim Thema Migration Meloni will die
Zuwanderung sehr stark einschränken
Scholz findet das Europa Zuwanderung
braucht
Einwanderung ist auch ein
Sicherheitsproblem und wir sind alle
aufgerufen Verantwortung zu zeigen im
Gegenzug finde ich aber und das ist
glaube ich wichtig muss das legale Wege
geben um in die Europäische Union
einzuwandern besonders laut hat Meloni
stets das mächtige deutsch-französische
Duo kritisiert obwohl es mit melonis
Vorgänger mit Mario Draghi zum Schluss
er ein Trio war das kommt so schnell
nicht zurück ich habe nie gesagt dass
ich gegen Deutsch allergisch bin ich
finde es nur unheimlich kompliziert
grammatikalisch es ist kompliziert
zwischen Italien und Deutschland es ist
noch nicht klar ob Georgia Meloni die
gemäßigte neue ist oder die vor der die
Partei von Olaf Scholz immer gewarnt hat
1 steht schon vor der Wiederholungswahl
zum Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus Fest eine
Wahlbeteiligung von 75 Prozent wie bei
der ersten Abstimmung im letzten
September wird es in zehn Tagen sicher
nicht geben die Berliner sind genervt
dass sie noch mal an die Urne sollen und
unzufrieden mit ihren Politikern sind
sie auch das hat ein ZDF politbarer
extra herausgefunden wenn übermorgen
gewählt würde dann käme die SPD auf 21
Prozent die CDU würde mit 24% zur
stärksten Partei die Grünen lägen bei 18
Prozent die Linkspartei erreichte 11
Prozent die AFD 10 und die FDP 6 Prozent
damit gäbe es eine Mehrheit für die
regierende Rot-Grün rote Koalition von
Franziska Giffey
die Zahlen sind aber nur ein
Stimmungsbild keine Prognose und dann
ist dann noch die Frage ob die Wahl in
der Hauptstadt diesmal ohne Pannen
verlaufen wird Stefan Merseburger und
Markus groß berichten
ihre Mission ist klar Franziska Giffey
will Regierende Bürgermeisterin bleiben
das könnte sie wohl auch wenn der
aktuelle umfragekönig Kai Wegner von der
CDU tatsächlich auf Platz 1 landet denn
Rot-Grün-Rot mit Giffey Verkehrs
Senatorin Bettina jarasch und
Kultursenator Klaus Lederer hätte weiter
eine wenngleich etwas geschrumpfte
Mehrheit der Verkehr treibt die Berliner
um und die innere Sicherheit das
wichtigste Thema aber ist mieten und
Wohnen Das war es schon bei der letzten
chaos-wahl das Desaster bleibt den
traumatischer Erinnerung für Berlin und
Deutschland findet im Zumutung wir sind
jetzt die Lachnummer in der Welt würde
kann aber sagen das ist überhaupt so
weit kommen konnte also dass man das
nicht schon vorher gemerkt hat dass das
irgendwie dann nicht funktioniert ja
keine Ahnung aber
Arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahmen
sie haben schon gewählt
sicherheitshalber winterwall niemand
möchte ewig in der Schlange warten und
frieren hier und anderswo in der Stadt
sind schon Wahlbüros geöffnet das soll
entzerren ebenso die Briefwahl die
bislang stark nachgefragt ist in nur 90
Tagen muss die Wiederholungswahl
vorbereitet werden sonst ist dafür ein
ganzes Jahr Zeit wir sind sehr
optimistisch das liegt daran dass wir
vor unserem Zeitplan sind dass die
Vorbereitungen sehr gut funktionieren
dass wir auch wirklich viele
Prüfschritte schon eingearbeitet haben
vierfach augenprinzip teilweise sechs
mal verschiedene Unterlagen durchschauen
so dass da möglichst keine Fehler
auftreten und bisher toi toi toi sind
wir da auch sehr verschont geblieben
Vorbereitung für den großen Wahltag
Wahlhelfer Schulung 42000 davon braucht
Berlin mehr denn je um zu motivieren
wurde das sogenannte Erfrischungsgeld
erhöht von 60 auf 240 Euro für den
Wahlsonntag
läuft viele tief in Berlin warum soll
man sich nämlich nicht mehr dran
beteiligen dass es etwas besser läuft
das wird so ganz normal und ordentlich
ablaufen da bin ich 100% überzeugt
Budget knapp 40 Millionen Euro so viel
wie nie es gibt mehr Stimmzettel mehr
Urnen mehr Wahlkabinen
ich bin zuversichtlich dass wir diesmal
eine möglichst fehlerfreie Wahl
hinbekommen wir haben viele Aspekte
berücksichtigt die beim letzten Mal zu
großen Fehlern geführt haben und ich
hoffe quasi dass es dann auch von Erfolg
gekrönt sein wird
machst du noch einmal Berlin scheitern
diesmal verboten
wir machen jetzt hier weiter mit Gundula
und Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft der
Automarkt in Deutschland ist mit einem
Absatzrückgang ins Jahr gestartet vor
allem elektrische Fahrzeuge wurden
deutlich weniger gekauft deren Absatz
brach regelrecht ein Frank wird man an
der Börse das wird wohl Folge der
Reduzierung der staatlichen Förderung
von E und Hybridautos sein ja genau das
ist ein wichtiger Grund denn weil
natürlich alle wussten dass die
staatlichen Förderungen zurückgefahren
werden bei Hybridautos wurden sie sogar
ganz geklappt gab es im Dezember noch
mal einen Run den im Januar dann die
Ernüchterung folgte gerade mal 18.000
rein elektrische Fahrzeuge wurden in
Deutschland neue zugelassen maximal
können die Käufer von E-Autos in diesem
Jahr statt 6000 noch 4.500 € bekommen
für teurere Fahrzeuge gibt es statt
bisher 5000 und noch 3000 € Zuschuss und
20 24 sinken die förderprämien weiter
Branchenkenner fürchten daher dass der
Januar Einbruch keine eintragsliege war
die Menschen werden vorsichtiger mit
weniger Umweltbonus rechnen sich die
Stromer immer weniger das gilt besonders
für kleinere Modelle die
Wachstumsdynamik sei dahin heißt es
womit ein wichtiges Ziel der
ampelregierung ins Wanken gerät bis 2030
sollen nämlich 15 Millionen reine
Elektroautos über Deutschland
straßenrollen
620.000 sind es bislang gerade mal der
Druck ist groß es geht um die Einhaltung
von Klimazielen der flotten verbraucht
der Hersteller muss runter doch ein
Selbstläufer ist das mit den
Elektroautos nicht Politik und Industrie
werden sich also nächste Maßnahmen
einfallen lassen müssen Frank Widmann
vielen Dank
die Eifel Rennstrecke Nürburgring hat
den insolventen Flughafen Hahn im
Hunsrück gekauft für rund 20 Millionen
Euro die Ring Holding gehört einem
russischen Investor einem
pharmaunternehmer der auf keiner
eu-sanktionsliste für Russland steht der
frühere us-militärflughafen hat das Land
Rheinland-Pfalz bereits zweistellige
Millionenbeträge gekostet
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat das
Wirken seines Amtsvorgängers Joachim
Gauck in besonderer Form gewürdig bei
einer Feierstunde betonte Steinmeier die
prägende Eigenschaft des früheren DDR
Bürgerrechtlers immer wieder Mut zu
machen
gauchslebensthema sei die Freiheit und
die müsse mit dem Einsatz für Demokratie
verteidigt werden Gaucks Wüste steht nun
im Bundespräsidialamt in einer Reihe mit
denen seiner Vorgänger
ein Ergebnis aus der Fußball-Bundesliga
das Freitagsspiel ist in den letzten
Sekunden der FC Augsburg hat Bayer
Leverkusen zu Gast und gewinnt wohl mit
eins zu null
der spanische Modedesigner Paco Rabanne
ist im Alter von 88 Jahren in der
Bretagne gestorben seine extravagante
und futuristische Mode machte ihn
weltberühmt in den 1960er Jahren
gegründete er sein gleichnamiges
Modelabel als einer der ersten
verwendete er Materialien wie Metall
Glasfasern oder Kunststoff in seinem
durchaus exzentrischen Kollektionen
später feierte er auch mit Parfums
Jahrzehnte lang große Erfolge
nach so viel Dunkelheit Konflikt und
Krieg kommt jetzt etwas Schönes etwas
das von Freundschaft und Liebe handelt
etwas das Hoffnung macht und gute Laune
Glücksgefühle auslöst und Lebenslust und
etwas das sogar nachwächst Barbara luke
hat es gefunden
atmen
wachsen
das Leben beginnt der Kreislauf kommen
und gehen
was heute blüht ist morgen weg
aber da ist immer Hoffnung fast sagt uns
die Blume wie es geht dieses Leben
Blumen sind etwas Positives denn was uns
alle sozusagen an der Blume auch
fasziniert ist dieses Versprechen der
Wiederkehr über die Samen über die
Zwiebeln und das ist auch nicht zuletzt
ein Grund glaube ich warum sie uns
kulturell so begleitet die Ausstellung
zeigt die Blume von der Antike bis heute
das ist weltumspannend denn ein
Seismograph für die großen Themen war
sie immer
für Protest
für Liebe
für Tod
für Hoffnung
und genau dahinein taucht Rebecca Lewis
law mit ihren Installationen hier hat
die Stille Künstlerin aus Wales 200.000
Trockenblumen zu einem duftenden Kokon
aus Wohlgefühl und Tiefe
zusammengefädelt
ich hoffe wirklich dass die Menschen die
in das Kunstwerk eintreten sich mit der
Natur verbinden da finden sie dann
diesen Moment in dem Sie darüber
nachdenken was im Leben wichtig ist
Blumen als Kraftquelle über die
Jahrhunderte als Wesen die kommunizieren
können die Blüten des lungenkrauts
beispielsweise ändern ihre Farbe um
Insekten zu signalisieren dass kein
Nektar mehr zu holen ist auch das will
die Ausstellung zeigen Blumen sind so
viel mehr ohne sie sind wir nichts das
hatten gar nicht so auf dem Schirm wie
unglaublich wichtig diese Blume ist aber
natürlich auch für uns Menschen für
unser Fortbestehen für die Ökologie
Klimawandel
insektensterben ohne Blumen geht gar
nichts mehr
da kommt dann Miguel Chevalier ins Spiel
der Schräge Künstler aus Frankreich
greift mit seinen digitalen Gärten gern
mal zur Apokalypse und fragt sich was
wäre wenn
[Musik]
unser Leben wird doch immer künstlicher
wenn wir nicht acht geben auf unsere
Natur dann bleibt uns nur noch das hier
die digitale Welt
am Ende ist das wohl die wichtigste
Botschaft dieser Ausstellung
wir brauchen die Blume immer schon die
Welt ist so viel schöner mit Ihr und
unser Leben auch
[Musik]
flowers forever noch bis Ende August zu
sehen in der Kunsthalle München und nach
uns kommt jetzt die heute-show
und um 0 Uhr unser heute journal Update
mit Christopher Wehrmann uns gibt es
morgen wieder einen schönen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend am kühlsten in Europa ist es
zur Zeit im Norden Skandinaviens mit
minus 15 Grad sonst verbreitet in
Osteuropa 0 bis -5 Grad und so langsam
rückt diese kühlere Luft auch in unsere
Richtung vor in Westeuropa da erreichen
wir allerdings noch Temperaturen
zwischen 10 und 20 Grad auf der
iberischen Halbinsel hier herrscht
zurzeit nämlich auch hoher Druck und der
bringt uns morgen mit einem Zwischenhoch
Einfluss etwas ruhigeres Wetter das geht
allerdings nicht für die alten wir sehen
das hier in rosa da stauen sich ab heute
Abend noch einmal die Schneefälle und
bis morgen Nachmittag können da dann
auch 10 bis 30 für Einzel 50 cm
zusammenkommen im Erzgebirge sind es
fünf bis zehn für Einzel 20 cm vorsicht
hier auch für Schneeverwehungen denn
anfangs gibt es in der Nacht im Osten
und im Süden noch stürmische Böden
danach lässt der Wind aber nach im Osten
sehen wir dann schon die etwas kühlere
Luft in der Nacht -2 - 1 bis 2 Grad es
kann glatt werden auf den Straßen im
Westen ist es milder mit 7 Grad morgen
gibt es eine ähnliche
Temperaturverteilung 1 bis 5 Grad im
Osten 5 bis 9 Grad im Westen dazu ist
der Tag meist trocken weg sind bis stark
bewölkt die Schneeschauer im Erzgebirge
und der Dauerschneefall an den Alpen
lassen so langsam nach dazu gibt es im
Nordosten und im Südosten auch häufiger
mal etwas Sonne ab Sonntag frisch der
Wind dann aber wieder auf neuer Schnee
und Regen schwenken über uns hinweg der
abends dann wieder die Alpen erreicht
hier eine große Lawinengefahr ab Montag
setzt sich dann von Osten Herbert die
Kaltluft durch es wird trockener am Tag
sonniger in der Nacht frostiger tschüss